une siroter un cocktail dans une soirée
chic qu'on soudain dans l'assistance un
individu avale son cake aux olives de
travers on appelle ça faire une fausse
route dans ces cas-là il faut tenter de
faire sortir le morceau de cake aux
olives en pratiquant ce qu'on appelle la
méthode de emlich du nom du médecin
américain qui l'a mise au point mais
avant tout il faut demander à quelqu'un
de prévenir le SAMU au 15 parce que
votre camarade là il est en danger de
mort avant de commencer pencher le con
vivant en avant soutenez-le au niveau de
la poitrine avec une main et envoyer une
nuit cinq grandes claques entre les
omoplates avec le plat de l'autre main
si le cake aux olives est sorti le
convives se met à tousser par contre
s'il est toujours là où il devrait pas
il faut passer aux choses sérieuses
placez-vous derrière votre camarade qui
est en train de s'étouffer passez vos
bras sous ses aisselles mettez votre
point entre son nombril et son sternum
appuyez votre haut de main à plat
par-dessus serrez bien fort et tirez
d'un coup sec vers vous et vers le haut
l'idée c'est de faire pression sur les
poumons pour que l'air comprimé fasse
jaillir le morceau de cake comme un
bouchon de champagne et tant qu'il est
coincé recommencer les mêmes
manipulations jusqu'à ce que les secours
arrivent cinq grands claques dans le dos
cinq compressions abdominales jusqu'à ce
que ça